Sayoko but I'd be thinking part of that
take a Latin what is telling the kid she
works at a tap rapper Lexy Alize has
died at the age of 21 while the cause of
death is still unknown the heartbreaking
news was confirmed by her family on
Facebook her cousin posted these photos
along with a caption that read quote I
can't concentrate I'm numb I literally
cannot breathe rest easy baby you gained
your beautiful wings the rising star was
featured on tracks by rappers like Meek
Mill Drake and Kalani late night trying
to add your own you notice Dobies as if
in an argument
Kalani tweeted that she's devastated
writing quote my heart is broke weakest
saddest way to start a new year other
stars have also mourned Lexi's death on
social media while a tweeted flexy my
god man and youtuber jafer Sachi said
everything I did you always supported
you always kept in contact and always
showed so much love we were even working
on music together this one hurts your
talent is beyond powerful and inspiring
you